what's going on guys my name is David
Tommy and welcome back to the channel
right now we're filming on the brand new
Samsung S 20 altra in glorious 8k before
we dive into the unboxing I'm gonna be
honest with you only that first little
snippet was filmed in a que the rest of
this video is going to be filmed
directly off the samsung galaxy s 20
ultra with no external microphones
plugged in with no external hardware
just the 4k video recording with HDR ten
plus turned off primarily for the fact
that I've already recorded this video
once in HDR 10 plus kind of look
fantastic but the second I throw up the
computer to try edit it it was complete
garbage so instead of wasting my time
figuring out how to actually edit it
properly i've decided just to reshoot
this video and do it a hundred times
better for the simple sake that i've
made a huge error
smash that subscribe button and make me
feel a little bit better about it anyway
let's get into the whole unboxing of the
Samsung Galaxy S 20 ultra when you get a
copy of your samsung galaxy s 20 volt
ray it comes in a beautiful matte black
box with gloss black s20 ultra across
the top of it on the sides we have
samsung galaxy s 20 ultra 5 g written as
well as a blank side on the opposite on
the back completely smooth really nice
texture and I'm actually quite glad that
they've pointed out the fact that it's
printed with soy ink it means they're
thinking about their sustainability
they're thinking about the environment
and they want to make a point about it
so a little bit of a point there for
Samsung just for pointing that out when
we open the box inside you will find the
samsung galaxy s 20 old truck obviously
inside my box you're just going to find
a bunch of empty boxes and already
headphones that I'm never going to use
from this device because I've already
unboxed mine and you're watching what
was definitely my first unboxing
experience but I couldn't wait to put
together a whole video so I just
recorded that unboxing and I'm compiling
the rest of the video now we're just
given me about a week to reference mkbhd
to actually have a play with this and
give you my first impressions of the
actual device so what you'll notice
unboxing this device is the black bottom
that I purchased is very very black it
is almost so hard to say even under
studio lighting conditions something
that's kind of interesting but also
really good unfortunately this does not
mean it is not a fingerprint magnet
there are fingerprints all over this
device the second you pick it up and if
you think the camera bump is immune to
these fingerprints are sorry the camera
bump being so big and pretty dominant on
the back of the phone I can guarantee
you you're going to be touching the
camera bump 24/7 underneath the phone
and underneath the molding of the
plastic you're going to find the 25 watt
charger this in my experience so far has
been more than enough to get me through
a quick charge it'll do from about 10
percent battery to a hundred percent in
57 minutes so that's pretty quick for me
I don't think personally you need to go
out and purchase the 40 watt charger
unless you're really desperate for a
really quick charge how about an Alec
Alec from flat to full is pretty good in
my opinion included in the box obviously
is a USBC to USBC cable you're also
going to get in the box
some USB C headphones which I haven't
tested out I've had no need for they're
usually pretty decent from Samsung
because they are partnered with a k2 G
which is also the brand there
makes their Samsung Galaxy buds plus
speaking the buds plus I have put in my
redemption order to get my free buds
plus with these galliston device
considering I already have one I will be
giving it away to one of you guys so if
it's something that interests you smash
that subscribe button and be the first
to know when I launch the video with the
giveaway once you've pretty much torn
down this box you're gonna notice that
something's probably missing you're
actually gonna find another little box
is stuffed into the box so you're gonna
have to rip it out and pull out the
little plastic case inside this also
plays host to the sim card and microSD
pin to pop out that tray and a couple
other instruction booklets too so now
that we've unboxed the phone and taken
about four days to transfer all our
stuff over and get all our accounts set
up I actually got to use this device
properly for the first time the thing
that I noticed straight away personally
the reason I bought this phone was
because the camera is I've dived
straight into the camera straight away
the camera quality is really good I'm
not going to take anything away from
this device because the quality is
amazing however coming from a DSLR
background and somebody who's looking to
replace the DSLR setup with a mobile
setup I find it a bit annoying and
frustrating that Samsung's promised all
these features like super steady 8k 4k
but then they've gone ahead and removed
selective features from selective other
features I'm giving an example in 4k
when you turn 4k video recording mode on
or when you turn a K video recording on
it removes super steady and also removed
auto focus tracking so if I wanted to
lock in on my face move around it
wouldn't stay focused on me in the frame
whereas if you bring it down to 1080p
then you will get that feature I know
that's not too much of a big deal
but then when you go to the video
setting
go to pro video mode which is something
I was planning on using all the time you
don't have the ability to switch between
the cameras you can only use the main
camera and it's also punched in pretty
significantly so this is a bit of a
letdown that Samsung has gone ahead and
removed a whole bunch of features from
the device that is more than capable of
doing everything that is my number one
letdown from this phone on my first
impressions so far is the fact that yes
it has all these amazing features but
then it goes and rips them away from you
guys now I'm sorry I made you can't use
them on that setting so hopefully this
is going to get fixed with a software
update hopefully we're going to see
something in the very near future but I
haven't heard anything from Samson I
haven't heard anything on the Internet
and I don't see it happening in the very
near future unfortunately what you may
notice on this video is the hunting for
focus is a little bit different and
that's for the simple fact that the s20
ultra doesn't have dual pixel autofocus
now what that means is usually you're
gonna see a video especially some of our
larger youtubers where the dual pixel
autofocus always hunts for the face and
always hunts to stay in focus the s20
ultra on the other hand uses phase
focusing and phase pixel detection so
what that means is it won't hunt as much
but it will instantaneously find it when
it does this isn't so much of a problem
but it does mean it takes a little bit
longer to find the focus and on the AKB
a recording mode it constantly hunts
it's always thinking it's InFocus it's
always transitioning to that next focal
point this is a software glitch in the
actual device and Samsung has come out
and said they are fixing it they're
aware of it it will be in an update very
soon which is very good to hear moving
away from the camera now and onto the
actual features of the device the device
itself is huge I came from a Samsung si+
background so I don't usually upgrade my
personal phones every three years
that's my cycle it is definitely a
different beast in there
and unfortunately because of the large
camera bump at the back which is quite
intimidating to look at if I do say so
myself it's basically like looking at
that thing it is a little bit
off-balance
so the way I hold my phone is pretty
much dead center of the phone that
balance on my index finger because this
phone is weighted more towards the top
because the camera bump it tends to lean
pretty quickly when I let go of my thumb
so that's just something I'm gonna have
to get used to whilst using this phone
on the plus side however the display is
phenomenal when I took it out of the box
one of the first things I did was go to
the settings display and change that
from 60 to 120 straight away full
disclosure I've never used a 120 her
refresh rate in a real in-depth kind of
review experience in the past I've
always been used to sixty hurt refresh
rates and I didn't think it was too much
of a big deal I thought my people just
made a huge deal of this it's the same
stuff
but when you actually have a phone in
your hand that has the ability to go
from 60 to 120 in the blink of an eye
and you can actually instantly notice
the difference there is a big difference
I've tried to screen record this which
is a fantastic new feature on the s20
happy about that one to display the
actual differences between 60 Hertz and
120 Hertz when you're in 60 Hertz mode
you might notice that it kind of
pixelated as you scroll up and down but
when you jump to 120 Hertz it's a lot
smoother a lot more fluid and kind of
more natural in a sense as a million-one
other people have already said when
you're in 120 Hertz mode unfortunately
you can't bump it up to the max
resolution that the Samsung S 20 ultra
can do you can only have this maximum
resolution on 63rd display mode now
Samsung has come out and said that's
because of a battery issue but it has
5000 amps in the battery so I don't know
personally I'd like to see that option
unlocked later down the track or even as
soon as they fix that okay
hunting mode that's really all I have
for you guys today the unboxing and the
first impressions are very very
important because you kind of get a
sense of what the phone's going to be
like next week I'm going to be putting
together a full camera review and I'm
going to be testing it against a
full-frame DSLR camera so we're gonna
see if my 2000 Australian dollar
investment can actually stand up to my
three four thousand dollar camera
sitting there hopefully we're going to
get some very interesting results and so
far what I've played around with this
camera is I know we are going to get
some very interesting results so stay
tuned for that if it's something that
interests you smash that subscribe
button down below
20:20 style and as always I'll see you
next Monday